[Musique]
c'est le sprint final avant le 8
novembre chaque partie dépêche s'est
ténor pour mobiliser les troupes et
surtout inciter les gens à voter
il y va de votre sécurité sociale de vos
soins médicaux du Barack Obama
[Applaudissements]
dit-il des millions d'illégaux
envahissent notre pays dit dans notre
chambre qui n'a toujours pas digéré cet
effet de 2020
et de race
[Musique]
une fois de plus deux Amériques
s'opposent
c'est l'élection la plus importante de
notre histoire dit le président Biden
notre démocratie est littéralement jeu
démocrates pourraient perdre leur siège
au Nevada le républicain a de mon accent
devant cette actual sénatrice démocrate
avec 46,9% des intentions de vote contre
45.7 pour son adversaire
en Géorgie aussi le candidat à
républicain est en avance d'un dixième
de points et pourrait ravir le siège au
sénateur démocrate Rafael warnak
la sénatrice Maggie Hassan devance de
deux points seulement le républicain
down Bolduc qui hésitent toujours à
reconnaître les élections
présidentielles de 2020
en Pennsylvanie et Barack Obama est venu
prêter main forte à John Feldman et
Donald Trump a même été les deux
candidats sont au coude à coudre au
Wisconsin le démocrate mander the bornes
tente de ravir le siège de rangerson en
Caroline du Nord et en ohayau les cours
sont également serrés les républicains
pourraient remporter cinq sièges de plus
au Sénat selon les sondages actuellement
chaque camp dispose de 50 élus
la voix de la vice-présidente est
décisive en cas d'égalité en Arizona le
sénateur démocrate Marcelé dépasse de
peu son rival Blake masters et pourrait
aussi perdre son siège
on élit des membres du Congrès dans ces
élections de mi-mandat mais également
des gouverneurs des secrétaires d'État
la démocratie est tempérée l'en Arizona
lance Barack Obama
si vous avez un gouverneur un sénateur
un secrétaire d'État dit-il qui ne
reconnaissent pas les élections de 2020
[Applaudissements]
la démocratie ne survivra pas en Arizona
dit-il
[Applaudissements]
cette élection n'est pas un référendum
dit-il mais un choix entre deux visions
fondamentalement différente de la mairie
du Canada Washington